Making a movie might seem like relatively
harmless make-believe most of the time,
but sometimes those fake action
scenes have painful consequences.
From action stars to comedy legends, all these
actors got knocked out while making a movie.
Few actors have been bonked and bruised
in the name of cinema quite as often or
as famously as Jackie Chan. He broke his eye
socket while shooting 1978's "Drunken Master."
He dislocated his pelvis and sustained second
degree burns and spinal damage while shooting
the explosive pole-slide conclusion of "Police
Story." He even cracked his skull open while
shooting 1986's "Armor of God," arguably the most
serious and squirm-inducing injury in his career.
That particular injury, in fact,
is so famous that Chan has invited
other celebrities to occasionally feel the
hole where a part of his skull used to be.
According to his autobiography, "I Am Jackie
Chan: My Life in Action," Chan was also knocked
unconscious while filming the 1976 movie "Hand
of Death." As Chan tells it, he hit his head
after a stunt that involved a particularly
daring fall. Despite the pain of the impact,
he immediately performed the stunt again to get
the shot, before finally passing out. Supposedly,
director John Woo was convinced that Chan was
going to die until the actor woke up an hour
later. Unfortunately, this would prove to be his
first major concussion in a career full of them.
Frankly, it's a miracle that the legendary Buster
Keaton made it out of the movie-making business
in (mostly) one piece. Heck, the man broke his
ankle while goofing off on a moving staircase
during the shoot of "The Electric House." And
according to Marion Meade's Keaton biography
"Cut to the Chase," the silent star
even fractured his neck during the
filming of "Sherlock Jr" when a geyser
from a water tower knocked him flat.
Keaton, a genius of both physical comedy
and death-defying action sequences,
famously never refused a stunt, however
dangerous. In 1926's "The General," Keaton's
re-telling of the true Civil War story of
a runaway locomotive stolen by Union spies,
Keaton was knocked unconscious
when he was standing too close
to a Civil War replica cannon that fired
prematurely. That's commitment to craft.
In the second cinematic outing of Jason Bourne,
"The Bourne Supremacy," everyone's favorite
amnesiac CIA assassin has his peaceful life
threatened by a conspiracy involving Russian
documents, which naturally has something to
do with the nefarious Operation Treadstone.
Bourne's covert adventure takes
him to an airport in Naples,
where he allows himself to get spotted
by security and taken into custody.
During his interrogation, he overpowers CIA
officer John Nevins to get his SIM card.
As director Paul Greengrass explains
on the film's director's commentary,
the execution of the fight scene
didn't quite go as planned. Reportedly,
Bourne star Matt Damon's flying fists
actually came into contact with Tim Griffin,
the actor playing Nevins,
accidentally knocking him out cold.
While Greengrass' infamous shaky
cam makes the hit hard to catch,
if you have the luxury of replaying the punch
frame-by-frame, you'll indeed be treated to
a high-speed smack that looks like it hurt big
time. To his credit, from what we see on-screen,
Damon doesn't break character. Hey,
remind us not to mess with Matt Damon.
What if "Death Race 2000" was a whimsical
slapstick comedy? Well, good news, that movie
exists, and it's called "The Great Race." Blake
Edwards' 1965 film tells the unapologetically
capitalistic tale of professional daredevil
the Great Leslie, who convinces automotive
manufacturers that a race from New York to Paris
will increase car sales. The Great Leslie's
arch-nemesis — the mustachioed, black-suited
Professor Fate — vows to vanquish his blue-eyed
foe by way of a car of his own invention that
features, among other things, hydraulic stilts.
"The Great Race" is the proud recipient of a
couple of cinematic superlatives, including what
a 1965 edition of LIFE Magazine dubbed as the
"greatest pie fight ever." The scene featured
4,000 cream pies on one massive set, and was
shot over five days. As fun as the ordeal sounds,
things steadily took a turn for the dangerous
as the shoot wore on. In the LIFE article,
star Jack Lemmon, who played Professor Fate,
claimed that he got knocked out a couple of times,
noting that getting smacked with a high flying
pie feels, quote, "like a ton of cement."
The same article describes how, at one
point, actress Natalie Wood choked briefly
when a pie flew directly into her mouth.
Who knew pies could be so dangerous?
"Bad Boys" is a seminal
piece of 1990s action cinema,
as well as a testament to the on-screen power
of both Will Smith and director Michael Bay.
The film tells the story of two Miami
cops — one a family man, the other
a womanizer — who have 72 hours to reclaim
heroin stolen from their station's evidence
storage locker. Actress Téa Leoni was along for the ride as Julie,
the sole witness to a murder and someone who
requires the protection of the title characters.
During the filming, Leoni was accidentally
knocked unconscious by co-star Martin
Lawrence's stunt double. As the actress
explained to Movieline in a 2000 interview:
"It was the AK-47 under the jaw that
got me. I wasn't on the proper mark
when the stunt guy hit me with
it. My legs went over my head,
and I landed flat on my back. Didn't
have much memory at that point."
As she tells it, Bay, quote, "freaked out" about
her ability to finish the film. Leoni was able
to pull through, and became a part of action
movie history, with the injuries to prove it.
"Bloodsport" is a film that could easily
be re-titled "Jean-Claude Van Damme vs.
the World." The film is a delightfully
flagrant excuse to showcase the actor's
talents for taking and dishing out beatings.
Van Damme plays Dux, a skilled fighter invited
to participate in an illegal martial arts
tournament in Hong Kong known as the Kumite.
Determined to bring honor to his state-side
father figure, Dux accepts the challenge
and proceeds along the long and bloody
journey of beating up the best of the best.
One of "the best" is Sadiq Hossein, played
by Bernard Mariano. During their brawl,
Hossein refuses to stay down and lurches
forward from his defeated position on the
floor to challenge Dux for a second go-round. The
script called for Dux to land a definitive punch
to keep Hossein down for good. Unfortunately
for Mariano, Van Damme's elbow actually made
contact with his jaw, which you can see for
yourself in the final film. Mariano later
told the South China Morning Post that the blood
you see in the scene isn't movie magic, either.
One of the most memorable scenes in Rob Reiner's
fairy tale comedy classic "The Princess Bride"
takes place when the newly reunited Westley
and Princess Buttercup make their way through
the treacherous Fire Swamp, which
is exactly what it sounds like.
Unfortunately, the pair's happy reunion
is short-lived. They survive the mythical
creatures known as Rodents of Unusual Size
and even pull their way out of quicksand,
only to fall prey to the ambush of the
dastardly Prince Humperdinck. When it
came time to film the shot where the prince's
right-hand man, Count Rugen, slugs the injured
Westley with the butt of his sword, the blow
didn't look quite convincing enough on camera.
In his memoir "As You Wish," Westley actor
Cary Elwes recalled that the Reiner solution
to the problem of making the hit look real
made him quite literally see stars. As he
explained in the book, the camera angle meant
that a fake strike just didn't look right,
so he told Count Rugen actor Christopher
Guest to just, quote, "hit me hard."
Guest landed a blow with the butt of his
sword, and Elwes woke up in the hospital.
Released 16 years after "Rocky V," Rocky Balboa"
is the sixth entry in the saga of underdog boxer
Rocky Balboa, and catches up with the aging
Philadelphia prize fighter in retirement.
He's in his 60s, widowed, and has a strained
relationship with his son. When a simulation
predicts that superstar professional
boxer Mason Dixon would lose to Rocky,
the undefeated Dixon throws down the gauntlet in
the hopes of finally fighting a true contender.
To everyone's surprise, Rocky
agrees and comes out of retirement.
As reported by The Guardian, "Rocky Balboa"
star Sylvester Stallone was actually knocked
unconscious during the shoot, and the crew
kept filming because they thought it was
all part of the actor's performance in his
most famous role. According to the report,
Mason Dixon actor Antonio Tarver accidentally
punched Stallone in the head while shooting
a fight scene in a Las Vegas ring, where
the 59-year-old actor promptly collapsed.
After the crew realized that no, Stallone
was not acting, they rallied emergency
services to tend to him. He was rushed to the
hospital and thankfully made a full recovery.
Ryan Coogler's "Rocky" spinoff movie "Creed"
sees former World Heavyweight Champion Rocky
Balboa serving as both mentor and trainer to
Adonis Johnson, the son of Balboa's late friend
and former boxing rival, Apollo Creed. Somewhat
appropriately for a film intent on revisiting
old ground, Jordan partook in the time honored
'Rocky' tradition of getting laid out for real.
"Now, you wanted this?"
"Let's go coach."
"I want you to make it happen."
A behind-the-scenes tweet by none other
than Stallone himself showed Jordan taking
a mean right hook from his co-star, very
real professional fighter Tony Bellew...
and falling flat on the floor. On "The Graham
Norton Show," Jordan recalled that the real
punch was orchestrated by Stallone to achieve
a convincing slow-motion shot. Unfortunately,
the first time they did the real punch, Bellew's
glove got in the way of the camera, so they had
to do another take. And it's this second hit
that dropped Jordan like a sack of potatoes.
While the actor assured the talk show host that
he wasn't "technically" unconscious, he admits,
"I was definitely seeing stars. It was
definitely not. I was not all there.
Smelling the canvas and
everything, I'll never forget it."
While promoting "Guardians of the Galaxy Vol.
2" on "Live with Kelly and Ryan," Chris Pratt
relayed the details of a stunt-gone-wrong in
his latest outing as Marvel's Star-Lord. Pratt
explained that he got knocked out while he and an
unspecified co-star were filming some wirework.
As Pratt describes in the interview, the accident
was the result of the stunt happening too fast.
According to the star, he was trying to
land on his shoulder when he hit his head
on a protective mat instead. Thankfully,
the moment of unconsciousness was brief.
"And I realized if I didn't do the scene I
was going to have to do the stunt again."
Given the amount of rig and wirework
involved in the "Guardians" sequel,
we're not even going to try and guess
which specific scene was being filmed
when Pratt came crashing down. Maybe
one day he'll tell the whole story.
Wes Craven's 2005 airborne thriller
"Red Eye" tells the story of Lisa,
a woman kidnapped by a stranger on a
routine commercial flight bound for Miami.
With her father's life in the balance,
Lisa finds herself dragged, unwillingly,
into assisting her menacing captor
in the assassination of a politician.
In one scene, stars Cillian Murphy and Rachel
McAdams duke it out in an airplane bathroom.
At the beginning of the confrontation, Murphy
rushes at McAdams, pinning her against a wall.
However, while filming the scene,
it seems Murphy miscalculated,
and McAdams hit her head for real and
supposedly lost consciousness for a moment.
The incident is included in the film's gag
reel, so clearly there were no hard feelings.
If you look closely during the actual
scene as it appears in the film,
you can catch Murphy's hand protecting
McAdams' head from future injury. How sweet.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.